In this video, we're going to show you how you can run a CI-driven scan with GitHub Actions and
Burp Suite Enterprise Edition. Now you can see in this repository, we've got a few files. We've got
our workflow configuration file, we've got a configuration file for the scan, and we've also
got a recorded login JSON file. If we take a look at the workflow file, what you can see is we've
got a few things in here. And one of the most important things is this write check permission
here. Without this, you won't be able to see the results of the scan after it's completed within
your pipeline, so it's really important that you include that. Now after you've checked out the code,
the first thing we're going to do is run our GitHub Action that we provided already in the GitHub
Marketplace. And all we're saying here is that we're going to use our URL and API key that we've
provided through secrets into the pipeline, and we're going to use our config file as we've got
in the repository here. After we've done that, we're going to upload the scan log in the JUnit report
file from the scan artifacts that are outputted, and then we're going to publish the report file
from that scan straight into the actions output so that you can see those results.
Now if we take a look at the config file for the scan, all we say is we've got the correlation ID,
start URLs, and all of this information, which is the same as what you can set in the Enterprise
console when you run a scan. And we also have the reporting section, which says that when we have
a low severity issue with a firm confidence, we're going to fail the build. Now you can set lots and
lots of things in here. If I go to this GitHub repository here, which is accessible through our
documentation, what you can see is absolutely everything that you can set for the CI driven
scan. I'd recommend you go through this in your own time from the link that's on the screen so that
you can see yourself everything that you can set. Now if we go back to GitHub, and if we go to our
actions and we run our workflow here, we're going to kick off a new workflow, and then I'm just going
to refresh the screen and we should see it popping up here. And if we go into the action, once
everything started and the runners picked up the job, you can see here that once all the configuration
has been pulled in and loaded, we're going to start the scan very soon. And if we go over to the
Enterprise console itself, if we go to our scans, you can see here that we've got a new scan starting,
and you can see this was started by a CI driven scan. So if we go back to GitHub, and we go to a
build which was already completed before, and we click into it, what you can see after the scan is
completed, when the logs open, you can see here that the issue threshold was breached, and we're
going to exit with a failure code. And now because we've published those reports, and because we've got
the right permissions, you can see here the tests that were run, what passed and what failed, and you can
see here through the annotations, all the vulnerabilities that were detected. And as well, if you go back to
the Enterprise console, you can see all this information in greater detail. So that's how you can run a CI
driven scan with burp, and with GitHub.